de lujo sigamos trabajando en estos
problemas y viene el problema número 11
el problema número 11 que dice lo
siguiente
sonia personaliza su bicicleta cambiando
la llanta delantera por una llanta que
tiene un medio del diámetro de la llanta
trasera guau estas son ya siempre está
improvisando a ver si me sale un poco el
dibujo am tengo voy a usar el mismo
color que utilizo para mi bicicleta
tengo aquí una llanta
efecto esta va a ser una de mis llantas
tengo por acá otra llanta y esta va a
ser otra y mi llantas y después tengo a
la forma de una bicicleta que se ven más
o menos así después tengo algo por acá
después tengo por aquí un rectángulo
raro digo un triángulo un triángulo raro
y después esto se conecta con la parte
de atrás con esta parte de aquí
más o menos así se ve una bicicleta aquí
está el manubrio y déjame ponerlo con
otro color por aquí tengo al manubrio
bien esta vamos a decir que es la
bicicleta de sonia y la bicicleta de
sonia es muy particular porque tiene la
peculiaridad de que la llanta pequeña
tiene la mitad del diámetro que la
llanta trasera es decir a supongamos que
ésta tiene un radio de 2 entonces ésta
tendría un radio de apuesta es la mitad
del diámetro entonces también es la
mitad del radio sería un radio de 1 muy
bien vamos a ver que me preguntan ahora
cuando sonaba en su bicicleta cuántas
vueltas da la rueda de adelante por cada
una de las vueltas de la llanta trasera
cuantas vueltas va a dar esta llanta por
cada vuelta de estallan está am a ver
fijémonos un poco en una vuelta de
estallan está si esta llanta da una
vuelta entera que es lo que va a pasar
vamos a empezar aquí la llanta va a
empezar a girar a girar
toda esta vuelta es decir va dejando
toda esta marca hasta llegar otra vez a
este punto dicho de otra manera lo que
estamos calculando es la circunferencia
la circunferencia de esta llanta trasera
que es bueno pues es dos veces speed por
el radio dos veces pin por el radio pero
en este caso estamos suponiendo que la
llanta tiene un radio de 2 es decir 2 x
2 esto por dos lo cual es cuatro veces
muy bien ojo esto suponiendo que el
radio de la llanta trasera es igual a 2
qué pasaría en este caso con una llanta
delantera
bueno pues una vez su circunferencia qué
longitud tiene pues la circunferencia es
igual a dos veces espín por el radio por
el radio vélez uno lo cual es dos veces
pin es decir que dicho de otra manera
nos estamos dando cuenta que la
circunferencia o el perímetro de esta
llanta de la llanta delantera
es un medio del perímetro de la llanta
trasera ahora bien si lo pensamos en
cantidad de vueltas cuando esta llanta
da una vuelta entera pues esta llanta va
a dar una vuelta entera
aquí me van a quedar dos pin y después
va a dar otra vuelta entera es decir
otros dos pin lo que me falta para
llegar a 4 pin si la llanta trasera da
una vuelta entera esta llanta va a dar
dos vueltas que justo es el inciso c el
inciso c lo que me dice es que tengo dos
vueltas la llanta delantera por cada
vuelta de la llanta trasera muy bien
esto es el inciso c así que vamos a
trabajar con el siguiente problema a
borremos todo esto y vamos con el
problema número 12 el problema número 12
que me dice lo siguiente en una lista de
números tenemos pe números positivos
eso es importante lo voy a poner si
tengo pe números positivos
p positivos positivos mientras que tengo
en números negativos por otra parte
tengo n negativos negativos tengo una
lista con p números positivos y en el
números negativos si sabemos que la
probabilidad de tomar un número positivo
al azar de la lista es de tres quintos
es decir cerramos los ojos tenemos aquí
todos los números
tomamos uno de estos números al azar
bueno pues la probabilidad de que sea
positivo es de tres quintos entonces lo
que me preguntan es cuál es el valor de
n entre p lo que quiero saber es cuánto
vale n entre
y bueno para esto vamos a hablar un poco
de probabilidad a ver cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un número
positivo de obtener un número positivo
bueno pues recordando un poco la
probabilidad clásica esto es exactamente
lo mismo que los casos factibles entre
los casos totales cuántos números
positivos tengo bueno pues tengo penn
números positivos por lo tanto en mis
casos factibles son p
porque tengo números positivos tengo p
oportunidades de sacar un número que sea
positivo entre los casos totales pero
cuántos son los casos totales am es lo
mismo que cuando nosotros tenemos
canicas si tuviéramos mecánicas
amarillas y en mecánicas verdes entonces
la cantidad de canicas totales espe más
n de igual manera aquí si tengo números
positivos y n números negativos entonces
en total tengo pm
más en números en esta lista p más en
números en toda esta lista pero además
yo sé que esta probabilidad de aquí me
dicen que es igual a tres quintos esto
es lo mismo que tres quintos es el dato
que me dan la probabilidad de obtener un
número positivo cuando tomo un número al
azar de esta lista es tres quintos y yo
lo que quiero saber es n entre p
entonces pues vamos a trabajar un poco
esta parte de aquí si trabajo un poco
con esta parte de aquí
utilizando simple sencillamente álgebra
a ver si puedo obtener el valor de entre
p am bueno pues vamos a hacerlo para
esto lo que voy a hacer es pasar este 5
multiplicando para camps y este tema cn
lo voy a pasar multiplicando para acá de
tal manera que me va a quedar 5 p 5 pm
esto es igual a 3 que multiplica ap más
n a 3 que multiplica a p
muy bien y de aquí tengo que 5 pm es
igual distribuyendo este 3 me queda este
por este este por este es decir tres
veces más tres veces n y ahora a qué te
parece si pasó este 3 p para acá para
que se reduzca con todo lo que tiene que
ver con p me voy a restar 3 p de ambos
lados de la ecuación y me queda que dos
veces p es igual a 3 n
lo que ya casi tengo la respuesta porque
yo lo que quiero es en entre p esto es
lo que yo quiero de mi problema si lo
que quiero es entre p tengo que dividir
entre p así que vamos a dividir todo
entre p y que me va a quedar ha dividido
esta parte entre pm / esta parte entre p
y de aquí obtengo estos dos se van que 2
es igual a 3 que multiplica a n entre p
y ya casi tengo el resultado porque
ahora voy a dividir todo entre 3 esta
parte la voy a dividir entre 3 a esta
parte la voy a dividir entre 3 de tal
manera que estoy este se va y por fin
voy a obtener qué
/ p que es justo lo que yo quería es
igual a 2 sobre 3 con un poco de álgebra
sal de esta solución que por cierto es
el inciso c ya tengo otra respuesta de
otro problema y vamos al siguiente
problema bueno y el siguiente problema
es el problema número 13 así que déjenme
tomar un color verde un verde pasto de
el problema número 3 que dice lo
siguiente
el costo total diario se en pesos de
producir x unidades de un cierto
producto está dado por la siguiente
función función esto es un interesante
apuntemos la función aquí se de x el
costo que depende de x es exactamente
igual x a 600 x a 600 x menos 200 menos
200 todo esto dividido entre x ya esto
le suman una constante acá más acá donde
acá es una constante y x tiene que ser
menor o igual a 100 unidades de producto
muy bien si el producir un total de 20
unidades de este producto cuesta 640
pesos
cuánto vale acá es decir que se produzco
20 unidades si x
20 x es la cantidad de unidades si x
vale 20 entonces el costo de producir
estas 20 unidades es de 640 pesos es de
640 pesos y yo lo que quiero saber es el
valor de k es justo lo que yo quiero
saber entonces pues vamos a sustituir
quienes se de 20 bueno pues te de 20 es
exactamente lo mismo que 600 por 20
menos 200 todo esto dividido entre 20
más k que por cierto yo sé que esto es
exactamente igual el costo de producir
20 unidades es 640 pesos esto es igual a
640 pesos es muy bien
y bueno en lugar de hacer todo esto y
dividir entre 20 date cuenta que 200 es
lo mismo que 20 por 10 20 por 10 por lo
tanto si divido entre 20 éste desaparece
este desaparece y éste desaparece debido
esta parte entre 20 esta parte entre 20
y me queda que esto es igual a 600 menos
10 porque esto ya desapareció y bueno ya
no tengo que dividir entre 20 porque
acabo de desaparecer lo más acá más acá
y esto tiene que ser igual a 640 muy
bien de aquí obtengo esto y ya casi
obtengo mayor de camps 600 menos 10 es
590 590 más cam es igual a 640 y ahora
para obtener el valor de cam acá va a
ser igual a 640 menos 590 640 menos 590
señor esto 590 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y me queda que khan
es igual am me faltan 10 más 40 50 a 50
el valor de acá de mi constante es 50
que por cierto es el inciso b
así de fácil estaba este ejercicio así
que vamos a resolver el siguiente
problema nos da tiempo de hacer uno más
el problema número 14 el problema número
14 que dice lo siguiente cuántos pares
ordenados de números enteros y positivos
de la forma x mayer
yo quiero encontrar padres ordenados o
puntos de la forma x con mayer que sean
enteros y positivos enteros y positivos
positivos cumplen que 2x
3 y esto sea menor que 6
bueno hay muchas formas de hacer esto de
hecho podría replicar esta recta y ver
qué es lo que me pasa pero se me ocurre
hacer una tabla es más fácil hacerlo con
la tabla x bien
dejen el dibujante que una tabla a estos
dos por acá y me queda si x vale 1 si x
vale 1 qué posibilidad tengo para ello y
date cuenta que no puede valer cero
porque necesitamos enteros positivos
entonces x vale uno me quedaría 2 + 3
james esto es menor que 6 a 2 por un es
2 y después si yo restó 2 de ambos lados
de esta desigualdad
me quedaría que 3 es menor que 4 o dicho
de otra manera
james es menor que cuatro tercios y que
el número entero y positivo es menor que
cuatro tercios
pues el único es uno si te das cuenta
uno es el único entero positivo que es
menor que cuatro tercios por lo tanto
cuando x vale uno la única posibilidad
que tengo es que valga
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando x vale 2
cuando x vale 2 me quedaría 2 x 2 443
bien esto tiene que ser menor que 6 y si
yo restó 4 de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad me quedaría que 3 james es
menor que 2 o dicho de otra manera que
tiene que ser menor que dos tercios y
cuántos enteros positivos hay menores
que dos tercios a ninguno no hay ningún
entero positivo menor que dos tercios
dos tercios es menor que uno por lo
tanto no existe ninguno si x vale 2 y no
hay respuesta para ello entonces x ya no
puede valer nada más grande porque esto
me quedaría algo feo aunque pasaría si
yo tomo alguien como 2 y nos dimos
cuenta que cuando vale 1 x vale 1 si ya
vale 2 me quedaría 3 x 2 6 y si hacéis
le sumó algo pues esto no puede ser
menor que 6 entonces la única respuesta
es ésta mi única posibilidad es que
valga 1 y lleva 1 es decir solamente
tengo un par ordenado el par 11 el punto
11 que cumplan que x y jenson entre los
positivos y además cumplan la
desigualdad 2x + 3 menor que 6 esto es
todo por este vídeo me quedé sin tiempo
así que no dejes de ver el siguiente
vídeo hasta la próxima